Okay, now we've learned about one gene. OCA2,
which influences eye color variation. But remember that
eye color is polygenic. There are other genes
involved. And it turns out there's another gene that
has a very interesting history for tying together
most blue-eyed people in the world. Most blue eyed
people have a common ancestor for about six
to 10,000 years ago in the Black Sea region.
It was in this region that a mutation in the middle of a another gene
HERC2 or H, E, R, C, 2. Arose within an individual and
began spreading throughout the region. This HERC2 mutation regulated
OCA2 activity and impaired its ability to make
brown eyes. Now, the HERC2 and OCA2 genes are
located right next to each other on chromosome
15. So based on this information, which of the
following could explain how the HERC2 allele modulates
the activity of OCA2? I want you to check
all the boxes that you think apply. Remember
to read each option carefully. If you have trouble
understanding this you should probably go back and
review some of the concepts in lessons 3, 4
and 6 earlier in the course.